s'il pas merveilleux toutes les vies dit
qu'il viendrait tu as osé conduire ce
malotru jusqu'ici lui permettre de
s'installer sur le trône sacré et je ne
comprends pas c'est lui et magicien
magicien c'est ce qu'il prétend
il n'était pas venu à l'esprit ne serait
ce qu'une seconde qu'il pouvait être un
imposteur ou services de la méchante
sorcière envoyé pour nous anéantir la
méchante sorcière ne dit pas tout ici
n'est pas à moi qu'on peut reprocher de
l'avoir sous-estimé revanche c'est peut
être toi que j'ai sous-estimé ce raid
qu'aurais tu décidé de te ranger de son
côté je me suis rangé donc écouter tu as
et je ne veux que la paix et je sais que
le magicien peu l'instaurer qu'il
incarne la bonté que connais-tu de la
bonté au fond de toi tu est mauvaise je
suis ce tempérament il n'y a vraiment
rien à faire